this looks like a job for the both of us
absolutely first of all you look amazing
as always
back in the suit for season two no and I
did not realize that I actually like
kind of color-coordinated with you
usually if I get tried the see nothing
else you have stands got it you got it
because I'm so pumped for season two
yeah this is my cousin Superman
questions how do you shave me in the
first two episodes we have Superman and
Tyler came on the show yeah what was it
like filming it oh my god it was a dream
he is so fun he's so easy to work with
Tyler kind of is Superman we would have
these moments where he would like trip
over something and I stumbled my words
and he'd look at me and be like weeps
people should just be rolling on us
right now cuz we're so ridiculously we
heard Clark and Cara wait wait wait this
has always been here we made me fight to
that cave every day we're in a new de o
space this year yeah this is the first
episode I think you guys are filming in
it this is the first day that we've seen
this finished and it's crazy it's what
would he like about a huge I mean we
were just in our cave last year but now
this is like we've expanded to this
crazy vast like Tony Stark looking
that's margul um Ray Palmer looking
palmer looking I'm kind of partial to
Adam like it's crazy yeah we totally see
it I've heard so much about this and so
excited with the other crossovers coming
up honey for Part C w crossover and it's
kicking it all off with Supergirl who in
particular are you so excited to like
get to share a scene with I think it the
relationship between Oliver and Cara
will be hilarious I just feel like
there's gonna be so much room to have
misunderstandings there um and I'm
really excited to work with Katie Lux
yeah she's a badass well and speaking of
badasses your sister on the show she's
more than a badge more than a badass
he's my heart how are we gonna see their
relationship evolve in season two
well it's only gonna grow and I my
favorite part about their relationship
and I mean I think it is the most
important relationship on the show we're
exploring every facet of sisterhood how
women support each other how they
understand each other how to communicate
how they love how they fight and you're
just gonna see more and more of that and
it's really fulfilling to play those
scenes I'm also curious to know how
we're gonna see Cara in Catco yes you
can moved on up she's had her working
girl moment exactly so what can you
tease I understand that she I don't know
might be doing something along the lines
of what I'm doing right now I know maybe
I need some pointers from you oh yeah
yeah yeah um basically color-coordinate
with with the start you're already like
a million times more prepared than she
hasn't been the season so far
okay she's she's learning now breaking
in the new shoes yeah and it's really
fun
you